all right let's talk about CPAC Texas
2022 it seems like every three weeks
it's CPAC it's actually not but it was
this weekend the conservative political
action conference Donald Trump spoke at
the event Donald Trump brought up an
anti-trans swimmer Trump tried to kiss
the woman and she rejected him this is
one of the absolute cringiest moments of
the entire speech Donald Trump calls
swimmer Riley Gaines up to the stage to
have her say some transphobic things
transphobia was the most reliable
Applause generally generating theme at
CPAC when Trump tries to kiss her she
flinches and she pulls away it is
absolutely Beyond parody let's take a
look crazy it was the largest Applause
I've ever heard come on up here look at
this look at this
laughs
wow Trump going in for the kiss there
and Riley Gaines coming in out of
nowhere and completely rejecting Donald
Trump a very very bizarre moment then
Donald Trump again spoke about his
former Dr Ronnie Jackson now a sort of
coveted conspiracy congressman and Trump
uh uh waxed poetic about when Ronnie
Jackson would look at Trump's body and
be just impressed with it Ronnie Jackson
my doctor doctor where's Ryan
where's Ronnie ah
he was the White House doctor he was a
great doctor you know he was a Admiral a
doctor and now he's a congressman I said
which is the best have you had your
choice
and he sort of indicated doctor because
he loved looking at my body it was so
strong and powerful
but he said I'm the healthiest president
that's ever lived
I was the healthiest I I said I like
this guy I don't know who the hell he is
at the time I said but I
so yeah I mean this entire healthiest
president thing it's so stupid first
because Ronnie Jackson didn't examine
every president like you know it's
totally conceivable that uh Teddy
Roosevelt was healthier than Trump but
also Trump is very clearly not healthier
than the person he followed Barack Obama
so it's just very very strange stuff
Trump then blamed High Energy prices on
the green New Deal which he once
abolished the only problem is there is
no green New Deal okay to bring down
Energy prices we have to abolish
the green New Deal
the fake it's a fake it's fake that it
exists because there has been no new uh
Bill signed into law that could even
remotely be called The Green New Deal
there are a few elements in what was
signed the day after this speech the
inflation reduction act that overlap
with some of the proposals in the green
new deal but I guess a non-existent bill
is responsible for high gas prices
around the world Donald Trump then do
you I don't know if you guys have ever
heard the phrase
it's a joke the phrase is I accidentally
the whole thing and of course the joke
is you accidentally what the whole thing
like there's a missing word Trump does
the exact same thing here saying two
years ago we had the greatest
in our nation unclear if it's another
one of his famous neurological glitches
if he lost his train of thought if the
teleprompter glitched who knows two
years ago we had the greatest
in our nation
what on Earth we had something that was
so incredible we had the greatest people
in our nation there it is uh very very
Trump even confused by the speech on the
prompter not a lot of Applause there uh
however there was a lot of Applause When
Donald Trump mentioned abolishing the
Department of Education I would bet no
one in the crowd has any idea what the
department of education does political
material to America's school children in
any form whatsoever
and if Federal bureaucrats are going to
push this radicalism we should abolish
the Department of Education
yeah
the Crowd Goes Wild but has absolutely
no idea what's going on
um remember when liberals were
supposedly going to put people in camps
Obama wanted to put people in FEMA camps
and global-ish yeah you know all that
Alex Jones type stuff Trump repeats his
plan for literally moving homeless
people forcibly into
um tent camps in uh outskirts rural
areas all of a sudden that'll stop very
quickly the only way you're going to
remove the homeless encampments and
reclaim our downtowns is to open up
large Parcels large tracts of relatively
inexpensive land on the outer skirts of
the various cities
and bring in medical professional
psychiatrists
psychologists and drug rehab Specialists
and create
10 cities you have to have a day of
tents right now they're living in tents
with holes in them
you don't have time right to build
buildings
you can do that later but you have to
get the people off the tree we have to
bring back we have to reclaim our cities
and now you'll have to there it is
officially saying we will put them in a
tent camp and that'll be it Donald Trump
then apparently confused about the fact
that unemployment is literally at a
50-year low and the latest jobs report
saw twice as many jobs as expected
created Donald Trump saying the job
situation is really bad in American
history that's why we had the job
numbers and don't forget you have not
good job numbers right now they're not
counting all of the millions of people
that aren't working if you looked at the
real numbers that 3.5 would be double
that maybe some people say triple that
right of course that's always been the
case people who are not looking for work
and are not working are not part of the
unemployment rate that was the case
under Donald Trump When Donald Trump
bragged about the low unemployment rate
these people are morons but the bigger
morons are the people in the audience
who fall for these stupid talking points
this has always been the case I Donald
Trump then also said some friend of his
paid eight bucks a gallon for gas
dubious because Trump claims to have a
friend that's really the part that's not
believable have it now at five dollars
six dollars seven dollars a friend of
mine from California called me this
morning he just paid eight dollars and
55 cents he told me California and
you'll follow yeah now uh the truth is
of course that uh gas prices have been
declining uh dramatically now more than
20 percent have gone from over five
dollars a gallon to four dollars a
gallon fifty four consecutive days of
gas price declines and even if you look
at California California certainly
higher than the rest of the country at
544 per gallon so continued lies from
Donald Trump at CPAC let's now go to our
interviews at CPAC one of our sponsors
is betterhelp the customized online
therapy service that offers video phone
and live chat with your therapist you
don't even have to see anyone on camera
if you don't want to you fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your
specific needs and then you're matched
with a licensed therapist in under 48
hours you can schedule secure video and
phone sessions you can exchange
unlimited messages with your therapist
and you can request a new therapist at
any time for any reason at no charge
talking to a therapist doesn't mean
there's something wrong with you it
means you're doing something for
yourself and for your Wellness you get
your car serviced you work out you see
the doctor to prevent physical illness
and disease therapy is the same thing
anyone can benefit from it I think it's
very important join the two million plus
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with better help get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
Pacman the link is down below